for Sims the bleacher report NFL analyst
warm NFL quarterback and of course
co-host with Mike Florio with pro
football talk live joining us this
program brought to you by the 2018
Mercedes AMG e-class with a suite of
innovative technologies it's one of the
most intelligent cars on the road go to
MBUSA calm or busy at local dealerships
go to your test drive today Chris good
morning thanks for joining us we'll get
to the NFL in a moment what do you make
of what's happening with Maryland
bringing back DJ Durkin you know it's a
weird situation altogether I can't say
then that I've followed it all that
closely I think that listen it's an
unfortunate situation where you would
think there would be better protocol and
things like that in place but to me you
know again I'm not going to sit there
and say that you know coach Durkin
should have never been able to coach
again in the NFL you know a coach in
college football ever again but I will
say this that you know the whole college
like you got to work until you puke and
all that old-school thinking it's got to
go it's stupid and their needs that's
why there needs to be almost like the
NFL where you have like that third party
doctor on the sideline there needs to be
somebody like that around college
football programs during offseason
training and things like that because
I've seen that kind of stuff at Texas
not that anybody came close to death but
you know it's all you know you're not
tough unless you're throwing up or you
know you're going and pushing yourself
too you can't go anymore it's a stupid
way to Train first of all science has
already proven that why do you train
guys to look like that when the sports
about four second explosions it's just
outdated and stupid from that standpoint
and I guess that's my take more than
that I think and you practice in the
heat and I mentioned the strength and
conditioning coach might be the second
most important person on a football
staff but aside from the head coach and
the head coach is the one who brings him
in right yes exactly right yes that's
the head coaches you're right I mean I
think he's the second most important guy
and just about any college football
program and yes he's usually a guy that
is extremely well trusted by the head
coach
and you know also I say to that too
about the outdated training methods you
know it just well why is an offensive
lineman running and doing all that like
wide receivers and running backs like
you know hey a rhino doesn't have the
same skill set as a cheetah so why would
we expect it to be able to do the same
things I think that's the thing that
drives me crazy
even thinking about back to my day or
even now when I see high school
practices or anything like that I just
go it just makes no sense that an
offensive lineman is expected to run and
have the same endurance and all that of
a wide receiver who's you know six-foot
180 pounds and has like 7% body fat
couple NFL things here with the trade
deadline I know we love to do winners
and losers here and a lot of times we do
winners and losers with draft picks but
I always say I gotta wait three years to
find out or four years if I won or lost
with a draft pick with a trade deadline
golden Tate's gonna play right away
Dante Fowler right away Demaryius Thomas
right away so let's assess it in real
time who was the big winner yesterday I
look at the Eagles is the big winner
I think the Golden Tate move was
phenomenal by Philadelphia and I know
that Philadelphia all we wanted to Shawn
Jackson and all that or they needed a
speed guy first of all Golden Tate has a
lot of speed still he still is explosive
has incredible acceleration you know
he's the type of player Dan that you're
seeing more and more at the wide
receiver position in the NFL which I
call wide receivers that are in running
back bodies right and he I look at the
Eagles this year I don't think they're
gonna get back to what they were last
year in the run game why sure they were
one of the best run teams in football
this year they're somewhere around xx
and football running Jason Peters being
in and out of the lineup they're always
having to make you know Lane Johnson
being heard I think they're going to
have to depend on Carson Wentz and his
right arm more this year then last year
and Golden Tate can do all those little
Tyreke Hill things that you see Andy
Reed do
Kansas City he can do the speed sweeps
you could toss sweep form like your
Donald Patterson with the New England
Patriots last week but I do think he
brings great value and I think you know
with Nelson Aguilar and of course Alshon
Jeffery who's the big target on the
outside but Aguilar and tape will be a
great combination
yeah there's similar players in theory
but I think Kate is more dangerous in
space or making plays happen with the
ball in his hand after they catch that
that's the one I'm most excited about
also because I look at the Eagles too is
you know I don't think they played their
best football yet this year and I think
they're a team that's still a Super Bowl
contender in my eyes and if they get in
the playoffs I'd say watch out in the
NFC if I gave you the Rams of the field
in the NFC yeah who are you taking oh I
would probably take the field but that
would be really tough I mean that's a
close one but I have so much respect for
Sean Payton down in New Orleans and
their style of football and what we've
seen them do just here in the last few
weeks you know they're they're a team
you know it doesn't matter anymore Drew
Brees you know he's got to be in the
dome to win playoff games you know Drew
Brees is phenomenal but they're a team
that showed over the last two weeks they
can win a number of different ways they
really can and that offensive line is
special that defensive lines got three
first-round picks on it and Sean Payton
how toughest teams are and his ability
to game plan I think is you know a
factor in that and then the NFC is just
so talented too and the other factor I
throw into that wood against the field
is the Rams you know as you know are
still a very young football team and
learning their way so that's why I would
say the field but I still think the Rams
are the favorite I gave you the Patriots
of the field oh good question I think
New England Patriots or the field I
would go with the field this year I
would I don't think the Patriots are a
slam-dunk to come out of the AFC this
year I still think that if Kansas City
somehow gotten to win going to come into
Kansas City in January that is going to
be extremely tough on the New England
Patriots you know I look at the Houston
Texans as a team that gets
playoffs with that front if they can
stay healthy and deshaun Watson the way
they're running the football they could
be dangerous
I think the Chargers are dangerous so
you know again New England New England
would be my pick as the best team in the
AFC but I think I would still take the
field at a close one there the best
corner you how about your opinion I want
to hear yours well I picked the Saints
and Chargers to play in the Super Bowl
so we were thinking alike yeah I picked
I picked the Saints in the Steelers I
had the Chargers d'Or the AFC
championship game but ok I like it dad
you the man just lay beyond bell play
for the Steelers this year yes he will
play for the Steelers I do think that
will happen
I you know they're not gonna resend this
franchise tag or do something like that
why so he can go down and sign with the
Philadelphia Eagles and they can hear
about it in their home state or he signs
with the Baltimore Ravens and then gets
into playoffs so that's certainly not
happening anything like that
I do think he'll play I don't think
you're gonna see a good levy I'm built
for the very end of the season and he'll
be in prime shape for the playoffs but
you know hey James Conner is doing a
great job there and I think levy all
bells probably probably every bit as
excited as James Conner that he's doing
that you know one of the big things well
bill doesn't want to come back it didn't
want to come back because he didn't want
to be beaten into the ground was you
know 450 touches this year to where it
hurts his future value and he's being a
businessman but I think he'll be back
there eventually
talking to Chris Sims from a pro
football talk live co-host with Mike
Florio bleacher report NFL analyst a
best Halloween costume do you ever go
dressed as your dad for Halloween no I
mean gosh I look just like it I dressed
like him every day I guess I couldn't
get away from people who couldn't even
remember my name Dan I mean they just
called me still or little Phil even when
I got to get a cell you know I get
sacked in a
bell game and you're the referee and
look at me okay all right sorry
sensitive still sensitive the best
quarterback in New England this Sunday
will be oh you just want like well you
know my thoughts and Aaron Rodgers I
think he's the greatest of all time but
I think that statistically would all
said and done who's the best quarterback
Sunday yeah I gotta go with Tom Brady
there just because of you know the parts
around him it's just too hard on Aaron
Rodgers it's always having to do it all
himself you know you've heard me say
many a times that that offensive scheme
in Green Bay is you know kindergarten
math compared to what New England does
isn't advanced algebra and but why does
allow that to happen he's he's got more
power in there in that organization and
Mike McCarthy does doesn't he I I mean
yes probably but you know again Rodgers
this is the environment he grew up in
you know I always say this to Mike
Florio he doesn't know what he doesn't
know right he's watching New England
film and gone dead and you know
unfortunately Green Bay still running
the same offense Brett Favre right in
1997 and you know like you saw last week
Wade Phillips I watched that film
yesterday yeah I mean it was like he
knew the plays that were coming
sometimes there was nobody open and it's
just Rogers having to make magic too
much yeah I just I know if the Packers
don't make the playoffs finish they said
it's over it's over watch them go Mike
McCarthy bit yes it has to it either has
to go or he has to bring in a new fresh
offensive mind that's outside of the
realm of you know West Coast guys you
know I know they brought Joe Philbin
back but you know Whoopie frickin do Joe
Philbin was there before it's the same
old crappy ideas how would how would ray
Rogers do in a New England system well I
mean you know of course I think he would
do phenomenal and I know Brady you know
I
a quote from Ian O'Conner a few weeks
ago on Twitter that you know Brady told
some defensive coordinator in the NFL
that oh my gosh if Aaron Rodgers played
here in New England he'd throw for 7,000
yards every year you know yeah I mean
you know again I'm not trying to knock
Tom Brady people think I'm a Tom Brady
hater and I just think he's absolutely
phenomenal and he's in always I really
do but Aaron Rodgers to me is like he's
Michael Jordan that is Michael Jordan
he's he is in another world I just go
it's the strongest arm ever the quickest
release ever
he's excuse me he's one of the best
scramblers ever he's the quickest of
40,000 yards and three touchdowns he's
the greatest gunslinger we've ever seen
and nobody protects the ball better
interception to touchdown ratio than
Aaron Rodgers second on that list is
Brady at three to one and Rodgers is
that for the one that's just--that's I
think that speaks to the incredible
talent and Aaron Rodgers has and I'm not
trying to take anything away from Tom
Brady or Boston the Boston mafia don't
come after me I still love Tom Brady
yeah Woody's trying to keep what do you
think Brady was out in Halloween oh like
king size everything you know King size
and probably like some New England
pinellia would like an autograph or
something like that
autographed picture he can't give out
candy Wow oh you're right it'll all be
very healthy organic organic granola you
know that's why you got to give the
autographed picture oh yeah man that's
Tom Brady but this candy stinks so you
got to give a picture to go along with
it with a signed autograph did your dad
feel extra pressure to give out better
candy growing up bill still does Dan
still does dad is like he's built this
aura and he will have a line going up
his driveway tonight and my sister is in
charge and she spends thousands of
dollars on the Betty my dad gets great
pride out of knowing he had the best
Halloween you know give
in Franklin Lakes New Jersey nice nice
yeah Thank You bud
talk to you soon man all right that's
Chris Simms pro football talk live
co-host and Bleacher Report and of OU a
knows former NFL quarter
dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]